inquiétude aussi des ukrainiens qui
vivent aussi ici à paris il ya une
manifestation en ce moment devant
l'ambassade de russie à paris bonjour
séverine larrouy vous êtes sur place
pour france télévisions et france 24 y
at il du monde
ou écoutez là il y avait au plus fort de
cette manifestation je pensais à peu
près 500 500 personnes de la communauté
ukrainienne ont ici à paris dans le
16ème arrondissement en face de
l'ambassade de russie ils se sont
rassemblés vers midi un moment il était
sur le trottoir derrière des barrières
de sécurité
la foule était très dense on a entendu
beaucoup de champs en ukrainien de
slogans poutine assassin poutine
terroriste solidarité avec l'ukraine et
aussi il y a beaucoup beaucoup drapeau
ukrainien bleu et jaune il y avait une
nuée de drapeaux tout à l'heure alors
les manifestants les ont plié enroulée à
cause de la pluie ici à paris mais je me
trouve avec les siens qui a tenu à
rester un petit peu jusqu'au bout de
cette manifestation les siens et
ukrainienne elle habite en france et
elle a de la famille sur place dans les
six a déjà une première question quand
vous avez appris le déclenchement de
cette opération militaire russe en
ukraine quel a été votre sentiment votre
état d'esprit retraite et ce matin la
nuit fut courte parce que j'étais
réveillé justement par un appel
j'appelle pas ça
s'appelle rachel militaire j'appelle ça
la guerre donc c'est la guerre et il
faut se rendre compte que il va pas
s'arrêter là donc il veut deux tiers de
l'ukraine je pense poutine je parle de
poutine ils l'ont constructivement
c'était quoi on a seulement c'est la
rage là je contrôlais russie large
contre l'impuissance de l'europe la rage
contre l'impuissance américaine la rage
donc je me suis dit on peut compter que
sur nous on va se battre jeudi la terre
va me laisser les vôtres russe on va pas
laisser rentrer facilement vous avez
encore de la famille sur place comment
ça se passe pour eux la famille mon
frère il reste en ukraine et à l'ouest
de l'ukraine et les réservistes donc il
pourrait t'appeler bien évidemment il se
tient après ma soeur qui était en
vacances lorsque la machine française
elle était en vacances elle a réussi à
quitter le pays son vol était annulé
mais n'a pris le car pour
qu'est-ce qui vous disent sur ce qui se
passe en ce moment sur je viens d'avoir
mon frère il ya une petite heure il ya
les bombardements longtemps les tirs
évidemment même si on est à l'ouest je
pense que depuis mon avis vous savez il
ya une petite territoire le kit est
annexée on en avait aussi donc il ya
aussi là bas les missiles russes je
pense c'est de là-bas ce qu'on pensait
d'eux qu'ils vont pas nous toucher mais
on s'est trompé
écoutez il n'est pas stressé il a pas
peur il a la rage comme moi ils secrète
dans les combats qui cette attaque vous
vous y attendiez moi personnellement oui
mais j'ai gardé l'espoir en garde
toujours l'espoir
mais je pensais que ça va se passer
comme ça qu'est ce que vous attendez
pour la suite et notamment de la part de
la communauté internationale
frapper plus fort niveau sanction s'est
passé c'est frapper directement poutine
parce qu'il n'était pas saisie c'est
saisir les biens immobiliers saisis on
peut pas saisir bon c'est la démocratie
mais ils ont beaucoup de biens
immobiliers les oligarques curieux c'est
poutine même à biarritz que je sache sur
la côte d'azur donc évidemment il faut
frapper par tous les moyens financiers
si possible évidemment un coup de main
militaire ça sera de contrôler on espère
parce qu'il ya la pologne les frères
polonais qui sont avec nous de tout
coeur
donc on espère qu'ils vont nous aider
dans quel état d'esprit vous allez être
ces prochains jours pour les pressions
je suis pas bien je suis mal merci
beaucoup les siens merci pour votre
témoignage voyez ici c'est l'inquiétude
qui prédomine la communauté ukrainienne
à paris qui manifestent devant
l'ambassade de russie merci beaucoup
séverine larrouy pour ce témoignage